you've always had a reputation of being
you know don't only a superb actor but
sort of a down to earth person who for
example you like to do your own laundry
when you're on location is that true
I've heard that about you but there's
there other actual deer that well you
did you said because I've heard that
about you and I can imagine that there's
a whole panoply of actor types some
would say I want this and I want that
and you like to do the laundry I do I
think it's you know I grew up in the
theater so you do everything yourself
right you know you put your own makeup
on you clean up around that theater that
sort of thing but also I like doing
laundry it's the simplest thing in the
world you know it's very sad I have not
found it to be the simplest thing in the
world don't you there I can screw up
anything that invite and I'm always
having I'm doing something with the
laundry and I try but I always end up
putting something dark blue with
something bright white yeah I do too but
that's not really a problem you get some
interesting mixes that way you're the
most optimistic man I've spoken to in
I always remember a friend told me the
Jackie Chan you know does his own
laundry
he went to see Jackie Chan at the the
amazing action hero start does his own
laundry yeah because there's something
satisfying and therapeutic about it
right went to visit him in a hotel room
and there was laundry all over the place
but I get it you know it's a way of
nesting if you travel a lot you get in a
hotel room you know yeah it connects you
it also it grounds you I don't think it
would crown claim I plan on away yeah
that's so important to you I've worn the
same underwear for years at a time but
who added that out so stupid I like that
though I like that and I understand it I
think you live theirs when your job is
to pretend to be other people
yeah and travel around the world into
these strange locations anything that
can normalize the situation I think
would be very good yep yeah you
chatterbox you just shut up so I can get
a word in edgewise we have I always
remember your interview with my good
friend Abel Ferrara that's a class oh my
god great director
yeah the regular director yeah great
director it was he was on the show nine
the funeral yes and it was a it was do
remember they said he was in the 1990s
and he was so great but eccentric fair
to say you read that yeah he did that he
did exactly that you can look it up
online he did exactly that he was he was
in the corner and I he didn't you did
your best
I did my best so did he he so did he so
did he
but did you know that before before the
interview started were n Rockefeller
Center the shows about to start
he ran away and our segment producer had
to run down this take the elevator down
and run down the street and catch him
and bring him back
this is an interview worth watching how
do they watch it Jeff till they go to
some site what happens I forget how the
internet works I can't hear you Jeff Oh
on YouTube
oh great no one gets paid go on YouTube
Abel Ferrara that was a I'm glad you
brought that up that was a fantastic
crazy strange moment we have a clear
prayer from the White House
anything we need to know for this moment
no look at it and if this time we'll
talk about it after
I love your Zen attitude course all of
this it's fantastic let's take a look at
this clip from the White House okay yay
and some lad with eyes brightness of
lady come to this rock playing the tough
you made me laugh with your false Grum
you pretended to some mystery in your
quiet jewels but there ain't no mystery
you're an open book a picture says I a
painted actress screamin in the
footlights a beach what wants to be
coveted for nothing but being born
crying about the silver spoon what sort
of in yours now lookie yeah what you
gonna do
[Applause]
right now that character would make a
terrible therapist
[Laughter]
[Music]
that'll be $190 absolutely fantastic
really I'm so happy for you
the lighthouse and motherless book
Brooklyn or theaters now and Togo is
streaming on Disney Plus in December so
you're constantly working always on the
go and doing laundry thank you so much
for being here